F: Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Laetitia. J'ai le droit de dire Laetitia?
L: Oui
on a le droit de dire ton nom et ton adresse?
L: Alors pas à ce stade. Ceci étant pourquoi pas ça peut être sympa si vous voulez m'envoyer des courriers, des cadeaux, des trucs comme ça, vous pouvez.
donc on disait que j'habitez
*rires*
F: La vidéo elle a même pas commencé qu'elle veut déjà des cadeaux la meuf
Laetitia elle a une page YouTube qui s'appelle?
L: Le corps, la maison, l'esprit
F: Et un blog qui s'appelle?
tu es vachement fort.
F: Et une page YouTube qui s'appelle?
L: Le corps, la maison, l'esprit
F: Et c'est comme ça qu'on s'est rencontré
L: Et j'ai un peu peur
F: Tu m'étonnes. On te voit ici, ici  et là au fond vous voyez
L: On se voit là aussi les mecs
*envoi un bisou*
F: Je ne sais plus où regarder.
L: Oui c'est vrai, c'est dur là, là c'est chaud
F: Ah un moment donné dans le spectacle je parle de synchronicité...
parce que c'est une notion que j'aime bien
La synchronicité c'est un hasard remarquable
ça veut dire qu'il y a quelques choses qui se passe,  et c'est un peu surprenant et ÇA tu le remarques
C'est une synchronicité
Je vais essayer, non pas de rentrer dans ton esprit aujourd'hui, mais de te parler de cette synchronicité
à l'aide des Rubik's Cube
C'est toujours facile dans les rubik's cube, parce qu'on sait pas les faire.
une fois qu'on sait le faire on trouve ça facile et c'est tellement facile
que dans les concours mondiaux de Rubik's cube
Ils ont trouvé, comment on pouvez départager ces champions
en faisant des petites cartes comme ça
Ce sont des cartes où en fait il y a un Rubik's cube mais il est pas fait dans le bon ordre
Et ça c'est plus compliqué pour un mec de Rubik's cube de faire ce genre de carte
L: Tu vas me faire des trucs de Rubik's cube?
F: Ce ne sont plus des faces classiques, donc là on ne peux plus utiliser les méthodes mathématiques classiques
L: Ok
F: Pour les départager on leur fait piocher dans ces cartes et ils doivent résoudre ça en moins de temps possible.
Et j'aimerai associer ça à la notion de synchronicité
C'est à dire que moi j'ai pris une photo d'un rubik's cube
C'est là, c'est dedans dans cette magnifique enveloppe
Qu'est ce qui se passe. Si toi tu te concentres dans l'enveloppe et que tu pioches une carte
Est ce que tu as quelques choses qui ressemble, est ce qu'on a les mêmes dominantes, est ce qu'on a une ligne identique.
Est ce qui se passe quelques choses de surprenant au point où qu'on puisse dire que c'est une synchronicité
On va essayer.
Tu vas mélanger les cartes.
tu les mélanges autant que tu veux. Tu les mélanges autant que tu veux
Et tu les mélanges comme tu veux
Ah tu les mélanges vers toi?! Mais c'est... bon
L: *Rires* Pourquoi les gens normaux ils font comment?
F: Je sais pas il les mélange sans les regarder
L: Ah faut pas que je regarde
F: Ah ben si tu peux regarder, je m'en fiche en fait
L: D'accord
F: C'est intéressant du coup?
L: *ri* tu es déjà commencer à me mentaliser là?
F: ah c'est possible
L: Ah m****e
F: Je sais pas qui mentaliste qui?
L: C'est bon
F: Tu le reposes exactement.
Est ce que tu veux encore mélanger, est ce que tu veux couper, est ce que tu veux qu'on s'arrête là? Tu fais ce que tu veux
L: On coupe
F: Alors tu coupes
L: J'ai l'impression d'être chez une voyante
F: Est ce que tu veux re-couper, re-mélanger ou est ce qu'on s'arrête là?
L: Tout vas bien
F: Donc là tu as fait tout ce que tu voulais toi.
C'est vrai. Je vais te demander de prendre la 1ère carte, de la retourner, de la mettre juste ici sur le côté
donc ça c'est, cette image là, je vais quand même bien vous la faire voir
elle ressemble à ça
C'est sur cette carte là que tu arrêtais après avoir mélanger, couper...
Donc on a sur la 1ère ligne par exemple du vert, du orange et du bleu.
Blanc, blanc, du jaune
Du bleu, du vert et du rouge
Dans cette enveloppe, je t'ai dis il y a une photo
Imagine si il y a une ligne identique c'est ouf
Si il y a 2 lignes identiques ça sera une vraie synchronicité
ou si il y a tout le tour et peut-être celui du centre qui change
On va voir le nombre de point commun
Qu'il y a entre ta carte et ma photo à l'intérieur
Alors sur ma photo je t'ai mis une seule chose c'est que le orange est mal pris donc j'ai réécris orange
Moi sur la 1ère ligne, j'ai juste comme ça, du bleu, du orange et du vert
Ça c'est la 1ère ligne
Sur la deuxième ligne j'avais du blanc, blanc et du jaune
L: Mon dieu
F: Sur la 3ième ligne,
L: Oh... Non *rires*
F: Je vous vais voir quand même, que tu t'es exactement arrêté sur la même carte que la photo que j'avais prévu à l'avance dans l'enveloppe
Evidemment je te donne l'enveloppe, où il y a pas d'autre trucs à l'intérieur.
F: Tu aurais pu couper ailleurs...
L: Elles sont toutes des petites différences?
F: Oui oui t'inquiète pas
L: Mais comment c'est possible
F: Tu vois tu te serais arrêter sur elle c'est pas pareil
sur elle c'est pas pareil
voilà sur elle c'est encore différent
L: Je te montre aussi elles sont toutes différentes
L: Je suis impressionnée.... *rires*
F: Je te laisse l'enveloppe, la photo et la carte en cadeau
L: Wouaaaah regarde mec
non mais c'est une truc de fou.
F: Et tu sais quoi Laetitia, tu pourras dire maintenant: "j'ai réussi à faire quelque chose avec un Rubik's cube un jour
L: *ri* Non mais attends je suis une meuf comme ça moi. Il m'en faut pas beaucoup. Moi je fais des trucs de ouf avec des Rubik's cube
F: Moi je savais quelle carte correspondait
mais pas toi, tu as mélangé, tu as coupé, je t'ai proposé d'arrêter à plusieurs moments. Tu as voulu continuer
L: J'essaie de chercher l'arnaque là, je comprend pas
oh truc de fou
ok
wouah et bien bravo
F: Merci.
Mais merci à toi, merci je suis ravi de t'avoir rencontré
vraiment ravi que tu sois venu au spectacle.
Allez voir sa chaîne
il y a des trucs de ouf sur le zéro déchet, sur l'écologie et sur... comment être bien dans sa tête, dans son corps et dans sa maison
L: Tu as tout bien résumé,
F: C'est vrai?
L: Je ne peux pas mieux résumé
L: Non mais parce que j'ai coupé comme je voulais quand même tu vois?
Et je les mélangeais comme je voulais
F: Exactement
F: J'espère que ça vous a plu. N'hésitez pas à vous abonnez à la chaîne c'est super important
N'hésitez pas à commenter, à dire ce que vous en avez pensé si vous voulez revoir Laetitia
Et à demain 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!
L: Et tu peux même le refaire ici, si tu veux
F: Et à demain à l'heure que tu veux sur le MentalVlog ou sur la chaîne de Laetitia. Ciao!